okay so falcon in the winter soldier is
very much set around the battle for the
shield
it's a symbol with a long legacy that
has had a lot of controversy surrounding
it
the item is something that can be used
as both a means of defense
and as a weapon and because of this it
really brings out the personality of the
person behind it
steve rogers and john walker are both
people that have portrayed the mantle of
captain america
and though they share a lot of
similarities the pair have one defining
moment that shows why one was the true
version
whilst the other was a failure we're
going to be breaking it all down in this
video but if you haven't seen episode 4
falcon in the winter soldier
then i highly recommend that you turn
off now if you enjoy it then please
click the thumbs up
and make sure you subscribe for
breakdowns like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the moment that
defined why steve rogers is captain
america
and why john walker isn't okay so steve
and john
as i've said do have a lot of things in
common both were picked by the
government to perform as pieces of
propaganda
that would help to solidify america's
stance in the world
whereas steve was a symbol of the
country during the second world war
john is one that signifies police
solidarity and this is shown in the
black and white flag that he bears
this is a symbol of that movement and
clearly the pair were picked to perform
certain roles for the us
they have several characteristics that
line up with one another
and both have performed acts such as
diving on grenades attending parades
and taking down terrorists the pair even
look alike and it's clear that walker
was picked as a means to reassure
america that they were safe after the
snap completely devastated the planet
however there is one moment that both
carried out that shows their differences
for steve this comes at the end of
captain america civil war
and for walker it comes at the end of
episode 4 of falcon and the winter
soldier
for context steve had just spent the
entire film fighting through thick and
thin
in order to protect his friend bucky
he's also fighting for freedom
and to stop the government from taking
control of the avengers
so that they could decide who to help
and who to ignore
both of these arguments were symbolized
in tony stark
who not only signed the sokovia records
but at this point wanted to kill bucky
because he murdered his parents
the fight is absolutely brutal but cap
pushes through
and manages to beat tony he pummels him
with a shield
which is a moment that you should pay
attention to as it returns later on with
walker
now at this point cap could easily kill
tony and he almost does
but instead he spares his life and
abandons the shield
in order to go on to become the nomad
the shield very much symbolizes america
and it was also made by tony's father
steve
casts this to the side to show that he
doesn't want to carry it anymore and
this defines him as someone that will
not cross over the line
in order to retain the mantle thus he
truly deserves to be captain america
because he is willing to question
whether he's even right for the role
now flip over to john walker who too
gets one of his mortal enemies in a
vulnerable position
walker very much represents order and
the man is symbolic of a police state
that enforces oppression
onto those that don't fall in line this
is given lip service by the enactment of
the patch act
which we discover in the show means
tighter borders and control
whereas steve was about freedom walker
clearly isn't
and he thinks that people should all
fall in line walker
is willing to kill for it and he slams
down the shield whereas
in the case of steve he decided not to
this is because steve is able to see
things from all sides
and he would rather have a debate that
he loses over stamping out the
opposition simply because they don't
agree with him
that simply isn't the case with walker
and whereas
steve stayed his hand walker drives down
the shield in order to kill his enemy
both tony and this flag smasher clearly
wanted mercy
but only one was granted and it leads to
this defining moment
because of the choice he made here steve
was able to walk away without blood in
his hands
or rather the shield juxtaposing this
walker is now covered in it
and it shows how much the legacy of
captain america has been perverted
it's a truly haunting image and it
cements the differences between the pair
and why one is worthy and the other
isn't to me
this hits at home why steve is the true
captain america
whereas walker is just the false one now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on these moments
so make sure you comment below and let
me know i also want to give a huge shout
out to user tick tock videos
for talking about this on my last video
as it led me to make this one
now as a thank you for interacting with
this video you'll be entered into a
prize through on the 30th of april
in which we're giving away three copies
of zack snyder's justice league in 4k
all you have to do to be with the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the characters the winners
of last month's competition are on
screen right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the
fourth episode which will be linked on
screen right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom and pointed out some of
the cool easter eggs in it so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more
without the way thank you for sitting
through the video i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace
you